quick reminder everybody remember to get
the free white paper on how to argue
about politics with people it's called
building arguments without Burning
Bridges we wrote it it's completely free
and available at davidpackman.com guide
few emails I received about it holiday
white paper sir I really appreciate that
you did this and I think it's smart in
my experience going head-to-head with
maggots is exhaust exhausting and
usually unproductive they will do their
thing and just make a bunch of s up
rapid fire while we scramble to debunk
on the Fly going in prepared with some
facts and where to access them we can
shut it down right away my parents
constantly spew Fox News talking points
and I can usually fire back because I
just watched your show and got all
informed like so I think this is a great
idea and we need to study up yes the
white paper provides a framework for
going into the conversations framework
doesn't tell you everything that you
need to know about every issue it's how
do you conceptualize these difficult
conversations particularly with people
who have been targeted by weaponized
disinformation Josh wrote in about the
white paper and says David sir great job
on the building arguments without
Burning Bridges white paper despite
being an inherently racist document
that's a joke because the white paper
it's a joke the paper provides valuable
insights and suggestions for engaging in
good faith conversations about difficult
topics I look forward to referencing
this document periodically to improve my
arguments and methods best Josh a
beautiful message of peace love and
harmony from Josh and then Mike wrote in
about the white paper and says David I
read your white paper
it's informative and well-structured and
thought out there is one fatal flaw the
assumption that the opposition has some
ability to be receptive to alternate
points of view dealing with the cult
mentality one must assume your opponent
is closed off to whatever your goal
might be deprogramming requires weeks or
months of intense therapy in order for
your white paper to achieve any modicum
of success the cult mentality must be
negated from the equation all others
would be fair game to your white papers
objective respectfully Mike I agree this
is not a white paper that is going to
fix your crazy Fox News uncle
at one Thanksgiving meal nobody is
operating under that delusion uh but it
is a starting point for for you to be
prepared for how to have the
conversation so get the white paper for
free nearly 4 000 people have already
downloaded it davidpackman.com
slash guide that is the place and if you
have suggestions for the next white
paper you can email them to info
davidpackman.com